my guest tonight of course a very
talented actor who played schmidt
on new girl he can currently be seen
starring in the neighborhood
on cbs and the movie promising young
woman uh which is in theaters and on
demand and it is absolutely amazing
uh let's take a look i just thought that
you were drunk
yeah really drunk yeah
well i'm not but that's good isn't it
i think you should leave oh now you want
me to leave
no it's just i'm really high
like i'm really high right now i don't
know what i'm doing
i think you should go but a second ago
you were determined for me to stay
you you're pretty insistent actually i
was a nice guy
are you i thought we had a connection i
guess
a connection okay
what do i do for a living
sorry maybe that one's too hard how old
am i
how long have i lived in the city
what are my hobbies
what's my name
okay i'm a little confused max
greenfield
is here max that was christopher mintz
platz that's you're not in that clip
no no i just i'm very supportive of his
work
[Laughter]
and i insisted that you guys showcase it
uh-huh uh-huh because i've seen this
movie uh this is a
terrific and powerful film you are in
this
film as is christopher minceplatz uh and
i'm
glad that you're a fan
well you know i i mean let's talk about
chris's turn on this film
[Laughter]
is this what you do you just like to go
on and you know paul rudd does this
too he comes on my show and he shows a
clip that's not his
and it's been no idea paul shows it from
a totally different story i know but i
love that you've taken a new turn on it
which is i'll show a clip from the movie
i'm in
just it won't have me in the clip that's
it well it's
it's just how unselfish i am conan
wow i've always heard that about you
thank you
that's that's what i'm known for and now
i'm just i'm taking it i'm stepping it
up a notch
wow and uh you know if i'm ever in
something
i just i want to showcase the other
people right you know i'm sure he's
thrilled
i'm sure he's told that they're out
there pushing we're all thrilled to
watch him
where are you right now are you
obviously we're i'm in an abandoned
theater
you are in your home beautiful painting
behind you thank you this is the love
a lovely artist a friend of ours john
brown um
he's the king yeah i am in my home
uh i should tell you now that
at any moment a dog
or a child could interrupt our
conversation or if you hear noises
that's just what
right it's okay i've been dealing with
that and uh
and we welcome it sometimes it's
delightful and kind of cute and
sometimes it's just
you know sometimes when someone says my
son may interrupt
it's cute when it's like a three or four
year old when
it's a 32 year old son who never
who never moved out of the house it just
gets sad
but it's also been 10 months of this and
i think we'll pass the cute point
i think we are